الضفه الغربيه حيث عم اضراب شامل محافظات
الضفه صباح اليوم حدادا على اغتيال
اسرائيل صالح العاروري نائب رئيس المكتب
السياسي لحركه حماس وجاء الاضراب بدعوات
من حركه فتح وكافه القوى الوطنيه
والاسلاميه وكانت المدن الفلسطينيه في
الضفه الغربيه قد شهدت سلسله مسيرات
ومظاهرات غاضبه امس رفعت رايه حماس والعلم
الفلسطيني وهتفت للمقاومه وغز
ال والمقاومه بالانتقام من قتله
العاروري هذه الصور تاتينا مباشره من رام
الله والاضراب
وعمليه الاحتجاج في المسيرات التي ترفع
العلم الفلسطيني
وعلم حركه حماس احتجاجا على
اغتيال صالح العاروري البارحه في الضاحيه
الجنوبيه في بيروت وهو نائب رئيس المكتب
السياسي لحركه
حماس معنا من رام الله مراسله الجزيره
جيفارا البديري جيفارا اذا اضراب كبير
والتزام واضح به في الضفه الغربيه ياتي
على وقع ايضا مسيرات احتجاجيه ضعنا في
صوره ما
يجري قد نقول سلمى انه هذا الاضراب غير
مسبوق من ناحيه الالتزام به في كل انحاء
الضفه الغربيه بما فيها القدس المحتله
بالطبع هذا المشهد هنا في رام الله يتكرر
في كل ارحا الضفه الغربيه قبل قليل انتهت
تظاهره هنا شارك بها العشرات من
الفلسطينيين من اطياف سياسيه مختلفه ايضا
من كافه الاعمار وكان اللافت ايضا مشاركه
قيادات كبيره من حركه فتح من بينها جبريل
الجوب الذي كان كانت تربطه علاقه وثيقه
بالشيخ الشهيد صالح العاروري والذان كانا
يشرفان على عمليه انهاء الانقسام وتوحيد
الصف الفلسطيني بالطبع الشعارات كانت تؤكد
على
اي مطالبه فصائل المقاومه في كافه اماكن
تواجد الفلسطينيين سواء في قطاع غزه او
هنا في الضفه الغربيه بتصعيد المقاومه
ايضا شعارات وجهت لحزب الله اللبناني
تحديدا بانه يجب ان يكون هناك
رد صاعق لاسرائيل حسب وصف هذه او حسب هذه
الهتافات التي رددها المشاركون هنا للرد
على اغتيال الشيخ صالح العاروري ايضا كانت
هناك مسيره في بلده او قريه عروره شمال
رام الله مسقط راس الشيخ الشهيد صالح
العاروري بالطبع الشيخ الشهيد كان ايضا في
هذه المسيره عدد من الاسرى المحررين الذين
اطلق سراحهم في صفقه شليط او ما عرفت
بصفقه وفاء الاحرار عام
2011 وكان الشيخ الشهيد العاروري هو احد
ابرز المفاوضين
لاخراج والافراج عن اكثر من 1000 اسير
فلسطيني وبالتالي هم قالوا لنا تباعا بان
الشيخ الشهيد عرفوه خلف قطبان سجون
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لاكثر من 18 عاما وما
اكدته والده الشهيد
اي صالح العاروري وهي الطاعنه في السن
انها لم ترى ابنها منذ اكثر من 20 عاما
سواء من خلال سنوات الاعتقال في سجون
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي او الابعاد الى خارج
الاراضي الفلسطينيه عام
2010 بالطبع لصالح العاروري هنا اهميه
لاهالي الضفه الغربيه كونه القيادي الابرز
من حركه حماس ومن القيادات الفلسطينيه
الذين يتم اغتيالهم على الاقل كقيادي
سياسي منذ عام
2004 الذي تغتاله اسرائيل وايضا هو ابن
الضفه الغربيه تربى فيها حيث ولد في قريه
عروره عام
1966 وعاش فيها هو يعرفها يعرف اهلها
وكانت ايضا قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قد
هدمت منزل الشيخ صالح العاروري منزله في
قريه عروره اي في الاول من نوفمبر الماضي
وايضا عام
2014 عقب اختطاف المستوطنين الثلاثه اذا
هو بالنسبه للفلسطينيين كاف هو وح مركز ل
القياده وايضا ل العمليات في الضفه
الغربيه وكان اصلا قد اتهم بانه وراء
تصعيد اعمال المقاومه خلال العامين
الماضيين في الضفه الغربيه شكرا لك
مراسلتنا من رام الله جيفار
البديري افاد مراسل الجزيره باعتقال قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عددا من الرجال من
سكان مخيم نور شمس في الضفه الغربيه وافاد
مراسل الجزيره ان قوات الاحتلال قامت
بتعصيب اعين المعتقلين ووقفتهم باحدى
ساحات المخيم كما اعادت اليات قوات
الاحتلال الانتشار في المخيم